[Musique]
Frédéric Tilli, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de votre
profession, de votre émission, de ce que
vous faites en ce moment, des médias, du
débat, de la liberté d'expression et
tout un tas de choses. Présentez-vous
succintement.
Fré Téi,
est-ce que je suis journaliste ? Une
bonne c'est une question que je me pose
tout le temps. J'aime mieux dire
animateur, moi. Animateur de télé, de
radio.
Euh ouais,
je trouve que personne se dit animateur.
Moi j'aime bien revendiquer ce titre.
Vous avez fait une sortie de ten truante
il y a un mois sur le service public.
Ouais. Macron est censé avoir fait une
sortie hier soir, aurait dit que le
service public c'est la honte de la
République. Si mes souviens sont bon, je
demande de faire checker en direct.
Pourquoi cette sortie un peu en short
quand même ? Non, on va on vous a pas
entendu dessus pendant un mois après.
Non,
bah à vrai dire, pour être tout à fait
honnête,
c'est un peu comme Macron. Je l'ai pas
dit quoi.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez dit ?
Non, mais si, je l'ai dit. Bien sûr que
je l'ai dit.
Vous avez dit quoi ?
J'ai dit exactement ou à peu près ce qui
a ce qui a été imprimé mais c'était
plutôt une fin de conversation qu'une
interview. C'est pas trop mon genre de
balancer comme ça. Et je me suis
retrouvé dans un le milestrome de
balance ton port, balance ta présidente
de France télé et cetera et cetera. Euh
oui, je l'ai dit, je le pense. Voilà.
Donc j'assume. Maintenant, je pensais
pas que ce serait imprimé. pour être
tout à fait honnête. Mais une fois que
je l'ai vu imprimer, je me suis dit bon
ben il fallait que ça sorte quoi. Voilà.
Ça couvait depuis longtemps.
Non non pas du tout. En plus tout le
monde le sait. Enfin tout le monde le
dit donc c'est pas grave. Après c'est de
le dire publiquement c'est c'est devenu
un truc
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent Mais tout le
monde dit que que le le la France
Télévision aujourd'hui c'est nul mais
bon à peu près toute la télé est nulle
mais mais France Télévision ça se voit
quoi. Et
voilà maintenant c'est pas trop mon
genre d'aller débiner comme ça mais bon
cétait dans le monde ça fait sérieux
c'est bien.
Qu'est-ce qu'on devrait faire pour
améliorer les choses ? Je pense que mais
moi je suis pas euh en plus je regarde
jamais la télé donc euh je je pense
qu'il y a je pense pas grand-chose sur
euh les programmes, mais il y a un truc
dont je suis sûr. La télévision
aujourd'hui souffre d'une érosion de
l'audience qui est essentiellement dû à
internet
comme la presse écrite. Exactement.
Après, il y a deux manières. Quand tu
vois ton audience s'éroder, qu'est-ce
que tu fais ? Soit tu baisses le niveau
et tu dis il y a plus de gens qui me
regarderont ou qui me le si le niveau
est plus bas. Ça à mon avis c'est un
réflexe de ceux qui ne connaissent rien
à la télé.
Ceux qui connaissent la télé, leur
réflexe, ce sera toujours de remonter le
niveau. C'est-à-dire que si France 2
perd des téléspectateurs, c'est pas en
faisant du M6 ou du TF1 qu'elle en
gagnera, c'est en faisant du France 2.
Les seules fois où le service public a
remonté son audience ou a fait beaucoup
d'audiences, c'est en étant le service
public. Voilà. Et euh et ce qui me navre
c'est ça. Après, je m'en fous du reste.
Ce qui me navre c'est ça, c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'on baisse le niveau tout
le temps, tout le temps. Et que c'est
une catastrophe véritablement parce que
jamais ça ne te ramènera des
téléspectateurs. S'ils ont envie de
regarder M6, TF1 ou je ne sais pas quoi
d'autre ou Energie 12, ils iront sur M6,
TF1 et Energie 12. il y a pas de raison
qu' il reste sur le service public comme
ça. Donc voilà ce qui me ce qui
m'énerve, c'est quand on a l'impression
que ce qui est intelligent, ambitieux,
haut de gamme, ça va faire fuir les
téléspectateurs.
Ça pour moi c'est la veu c'est la
rédition totale quoi. En race campagne.
Donc voilà, ça m'énerve et je l'ai dit.
Les préconisations pour améliorer tout
ça, quel type de programme il faudrait
faire ? Il faudrait refaire un ce soir
ou jamais. Il faudrait refaire du sur
France 2. fait le taf quand même.
Non non parce que non c'est c'est ça
c'est fait c'est très bien c'est pas la
question mais c'est fait pour 3 ou 4 %
des téléspectateurs.
Le service public c'est fait pour
beaucoup plus que ça. Donc
donc maintenant je suis pas directeur
des programmes. On me l'a proposé une
fois mais c'était pas sur France
Télévision, c'était sur France Interre
et j'ai dit tout de suite non je suis
incapable de faire ça.
Pour être directeur des programmes, il
faut regarder beaucoup la télévision, ce
qui est pas mon cas. Maintenant, je
crois à une ambition. Voilà, je crois
qu'on on peut faire une ambition
populaire et grand public, ce qui est
pas le cas d'Arté. Voilà.
Vous avez dit que ce soir ou jamais a
été arrêté parce que ça dérangeait la
direction.
Non,
ça a été écrit ?
Non, j'ai jamais dit.
Vous avez jamais dit ça ?
La phrase exacte, vous la voulez
peut-être.
Alors
oui oui, dites-moi, dites-moi.
Allez, on va la retrouver, on va meubler
en en attendant.
Alors, vous avez dit France Télévision,
c'est un gâi. Delphine Arnaud,
présidente du groupe audiovisuel tire
les chaînes du service public vers le
bas. Elle ne connaît pas, elle ne
connaît rien à la télé. Elle est en
train de casser le groupe. Visiblement,
cette émission intellectuelle dérangeait
la direction.
Ah oui, dans ce sens-là. Oui, bah oui,
forcément
les patrons les patrons de la chaîne
pensent que les gens intelligents
regardent de moins en moins la télé et
ce n'est pas la peine d'offrir des
programmes exigeant. Je crois qu'ils ont
tort. H
non, non, mais
bienvenue chez nous.
C'est que évidemment à partir du moment
où on arrête une émission, c'est qu'elle
vous dérange. Voilà.
Les audiences étaient comment ?
Oh, très bien. La dernière année de ce
soir ou jamais, en septembre, elle fait
autant que a toujours fait ce soir ou
jamais. Euh c'est à partir du moment où
on la recule euh d'une heure pour
préparer un peu les gens au fait qu'elle
va disparaître et pour pouvoir le
justifier par euh par le fait qu'elle
aelle a perdu et effectivement comme les
journalistes de télé euh tu peux leur
raconter n'importe quoi, il le croient.
Euh les gens ont dit bah oui, elle
s'était usée, ce qui est faux. Euh mais
la raison pour laquelle cette émission
dérangeait euh la nouvelle direction,
tout est possible. Il y a une version
paranoïque qui dit "Oui, c'est parce
qu'il y a des débats et cetera." J'en
sais rien. Je crois même pas. Moi je
crois pas tellement, je suis pas
paranoïque. Donc non, je crois que tu as
toujours quand tu arrives le drame de
France Télévision aussi, c'est que tous
les 5 ans la direction enfin la
présidence change avec la présidence
toutes les directions changent et on va
défaire ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait les
prédécesseurs. C'est le seul qui a sur
M6 sur TF1 les directions restent
pendant 10 ans 20 ans, 15 ans. sur
France Télévision tous les 5 ans. Bam
bam bam. Et à chaque fois qu'une
nouvelle direction arrive, elle vient,
elle t'apprend la télé, elle te dit que
la télé c'est pas ce que tu faisais toi,
c'est ce qu'elle va faire maintenant.
Alors ils te le disent plus ou moins
gentiment sur l'organisation, sur les
contenus des programmes, sur tout ça.
Bon c'est toujours c'est amusant et en
même temps c'est toujours un peu
dramatique. On a l'impression que voilà
qu'on repart à zéro à chaque fois. C'est
pénible.
Maintenant, quand tu qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire déranger la direction ? Ça
veut dire que tu les déranges parce que
tu es là et qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils peuvent faire mieux. C'est tout,
c'est souvent ça. C'est pas parce que
politiquement tu es gênant, parce que
j'en sais rien, c'est possible aussi.
Mais mais je crois plus simplement qu'il
se disent "Bon, de ce côté-là, on peut
taper parce que ça fait moins d'audience
qu'à d'autres endroits où ça en fait
beaucoup
et et donc tu les déranges parce qu'ils
ont envie de mettre un programme à eux à
ta place." Voilà.
eux dans quel sens produit par des
copains
ils sont ils sont parce qu'ils ont
généré l'idée c'est ça non voilà c'est
ça ce sera place ce sera ton programme à
toi et pas le programme que tu as hérité
de tes prédécesseurs. Voilà c'est tout.
Air
elle elle fait le taf, elle fait pas le
taf, elle compte faire le taf ? J'en
sais rien. Je me souviens que dans cette
interview, j'avais dit qu'au fond
d'affider, c'est pas elle qui
responsable des programmes. Donc mais
bon, cette phrase a disparu. Mais mais
voilà, maintenant quand tu es président,
tu es président donc tu es responsable.
Est-ce que c'est pas parce que vous avez
invité des gens un peu touchy sur le
plateau ou
non ? Ça c'est le côté paranoïque que je
veux pas. Non, je crois j'en sais rien.
J'en sais je sais que France Télévision
ne me l'a jamais reproché les deux
directions précédentes et de toute façon
il pouvait pas me le reprocher puisquil
savait très bien qui j'invitais. Vous
savez à la télévision comme partout
d'ailleurs, les gens que vous invitez,
vos patrons les connaissent avant que
vous les invitez hein. Vous les mettez
pas devant le fait accompli. Euh vous
envoyez à chaque fois
combien de temps à l'avance ?
Je sais pas. Faudrait demander aux gens
avec qui je travaillais mais comme nous
on faisait l'émission très souvent du
matin pour le soir, tu le renvoies donc
tu le renvoies le matin, on va dire ou
l'après-midi ou au fur et à mesure. En
tout cas,
il y a jamais eu un coup de fil du
genre.
Jamais, jamais jamais de ma vie.
Liberté totale.
Liberté totale. Mais pas seulement là,
partout. à europen toujours euh donc
jamais j'ai eu un coup de téléphone de
France Télévision. En tout cas moi
maintenant peut-être que d'autres gens
équipe diraient bah si mais je crois pas
non franchement on me l'aurait dit.
Vous avez fait à peu près un peu moins
de 1000 émissions sur ce soir au jamais.
750 très précisément
750 zéro procès.
Zéro bien sûr. Zéro procès. Zéro départ
si un seul personne qui a quitté le
plateau c'est Guedos
euh parce que il parce que en fait
j'avais mis que des humoristes et ça l'a
énervé. au début, il croyait là au
milieu des philosophes et il s'est rendu
compte qu'il était au milieu des
humoristes et au bout d'un moment, il
s'est barré en disant d'ailleurs, mais
personne l'a entendu et en fait personne
ne s'est rendu compte qu'il s'était
barré et il était pas filmé à ce
moment-là et comme il parlait pas
beaucoup euh et il a dit oui, c'est
c'est je sais plus quelle était la
phrase exactement, mais c'était pour
dire oui, si si je fais du one man show,
c'est pas par hasard, c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour partager la scène avec
tous ces tous ces humoristes et euh
voilà, c'est le seul. Donc personne
s'est personne n'est jamais parti,
personne ne s'est jamais plaint qu'il
avait pas pu parler. Personne ne m'a dit
"Vous m'avez désavantagé" ou je sais pas
quoi. Personne il y a jamais eu de
bagarre, il y a jamais eu de On a jamais
vu un cendrier voler. Euh c'était une
espèce de de lieu de où on acceptait de
venir discuter avec les gens avec qui
non seulement on n'était pas d'accord
mais que parfois même on détestait.
Voilà. Et pendant 1 heure
des exemples
des centaines enfin il suffit de revoir
les émissions. On voit bien que les gens
se haïsent dans certains cas.
Si c'est c'est chez vous qui a eu le
fameux taisez-vous de
Oui, mais c'est pas par haine. Au
contraire même le fameux Taisez-vous de
d'Alain Finkelcot.
Alain Finkelcrot aimait beaucoup le
travail de de Abdel Raouf d'Afri la
série qu'il faisait sur Canal Plus. Il
le dit d'ailleurs pendant l'émission,
pendant le débat et euh mais non non,
ils se détestent pas et d'ailleurs ils
partent plutôt réconciliés d'ailleurs
les gens le savent pas mais mais enfin
réconciliés ils sont pas d'accord mais
ils sont pas ils sont pas à côteau
tirés. C'est c'est l'impression que
donne la la télévision ça.
Un avis sur le CSA ?
Non
pas d'avis.
Je les ai pas tellement connus euh le
CSA.
Je les ai connu quand je faisais Paris
dernière. On avait souvent des problèmes
avec le CSA, des séquences.
C'est certaines séquences qui peuvent
poser problème. Ouais,
mais pas parce que non, c'était c'était
toujours motivé. C'était très
intéressant. C'était très intéressant.
Je me souviens qu'une fille qui
une fille qui qui dansait ou je sais
plus si elle se masturbait ou si elle
dansait sur une tombe. Ça le c'est ça
avait pas du tout aimé. ne serait-ce que
parce que euh on était on pouvait avoir
de la profanation parce que c'était pas
bien entendu et puis surtout il a fallu
grimper au-dessus du mur euh pour
pouvoir rentrer dans le cimetière donc
c'était bon j'avais été convoqué enfin
pas moi mais parce que je roulais vite
et que et que je buvais mais bon leur
avait expliqué que c'était accéléré
quand je roulais vite et que d'ailleurs
c'était pas toujours moi qui conduisait
c'était bon ils avaient bien voulu
l'entendre Endre. Je me souviens que
j'ai été félicité par le CSA une fois.
J'ai eu un mot en me disant qu'on me
félicitait parce que j'avais demander à
à
un célèbre patron de presse de d'arrêter
de mentionner constamment le site
d'information
qui présidait
et il le disait tout le temps à
l'antenne et ça commence à ressembler à
la publicité. Jeais dit s'il pouvait le
dire un peu moins souvent. Donc ça,
j'avais été je me suis un jour j'ai eu
un blâ pour une interview de Dodo la
Saumure. Il faut dire qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'associations féministes qui
avaient protesté contre l'interview que
je faisais de Dodo la saumur en disant
que
de lancier de la boîte à dans le
nord. Voilà proxenet en disant qu'il y
avait pas de personne contre lui.
J'avais dit que c'était pas un débat
pour ou contre le proxénétisme
parce que ça n'était pas c'était au
moment où Dominic Troscan avait été
inculpé de proxénitisme aggravé avec
trafic international d'êtres humains ou
un truc comme ça juste parce que il
avait été clients de prostitué. lui
disait qu'il savait pas que c'était des
prostituées mais enfin à la fin c'était
ça. Et donc c'était très intéressant la
notion de proxénétisme dans la tête des
juges qu'il avait inculpé. C'est-à-dire
en gros le client était le proxénet.
Donc je me souviens que le seul proxened
qui existait à ce moment-là, c'était
c'était de Dolis au mur qu'on
connaissait qui pouvait venir sur un
plateau télé pour qu'on parle de ce que
c'était que le proxénitisme quoi. Donc
c'était une interview de la Som
mais il se trouve comme il y a eu
beaucoup d'associations féministes qui
ont protesté auprès du CSA, le CSA s'est
trouvé obligé de dire que alors il
aurait pu s'il avait trouvé que mon
interview était lamentable, il aurait
mon avis dit des trucs pire. il a juste
dit mis un blame, je me souviens plus
quel prétexte et j'avais trouvé que
c'était une très bonne initiative.
D'ailleurs, je trouvais ça très bien que
le CSA commence à à blâmer les
intervieweurs pour leurs interviews et
j'espérais qu'il le ferait de même au
moment de la campagne présidentielle. Je
sais pas s'il m'a écouté mais euh
le toute la presse s'était penchée sur
Macron, c'est ça ou
non ? C'est pas ça. C'est que si on
commence à dire est-ce qu'une interview
est bien ou pas bien, je trouve pas ça
Moi, je trouve ça bien qu'on le fasse et
je trouve que le CSA devrait continuer.
Et euh
vous voyez président du CSA ?
Pas du tout.
On en est où en France pour créer des
débats, pour animer, passer les idées ?
Est-ce que toutes ces associations
est-ce que tout le monde tire le drap
pour défendre son bout de gras ? Est-ce
que c'est pas nuisible
à la pluralité des idées, à l'échange et
même au respect ?
C'est aujourd'hui, on est dans une seule
période. Il y a un côté,
je l'ai souvent dit, les fanatiques
donnent le ton. Quel que soit leur bord
de tous les côtés. Ce sont les
fanatiques aujourd'hui
qui euh,
je sais pas si c'est les plus écoutés,
mais en tout cas, c'est les plus
entendus.
Et c'est en fonction d'eux qu'on a
tendance à se caler. Or, qu'est-ce que
nous disent les fanatiques ? C'est que
dès l'instant où vous invitez quelqu'un
de l'autre bord, vous êtes complice de
l'autre bord. Pour animer des débats,
c'est terrible. Ça veut dire que celui
qui organise le débat et qui l'anime est
constamment
soupçonné par une partie du public de
faire le jeu des autres.
Euh c'est pas forcé c'est pas le cas de
des invités. Moi, j'ai jamais eu aucun
invité qui s'est qui est qui a protesté
contre un tel qui était en face parce
que la preuve c'est étaient venus donc
ils étaient d'accord. Ceux qui n'avaient
pas envie de discuter avec un tel et un
tel, il venaient pas. Et c'est arrivé
très souvent au cours des débats des 10
ans pendant lesquels on a invité des on
a organisé des débats sur dans ce soir
ou jamais. Il y a des gens qui ont dit
"Non, moi je veux pas discuter avec
machin." Euh et on a eu dans toutes les
cas de figure entre économistes, vous
avez des des ça m'est arrivé encore
récemment sur Europ, il y a un invité
qui est arrivé au dernier moment, il a
entendu le nom. Visiblement, il avait
pas fait attention que untel était dans
l'émission aussi. Quand il a entendu son
nom, il est reparti directement. dit
non, je veux pas discuter avec ce
monsieur. Et donc vous avez ça, vous
avez on n jamais compris pourquoi
d'ailleurs et euh
pourquoi je vous disais ça ? Oui. Euh
après, vous avez des problèmes avec les
commentateurs. Vous avez rarement des
problèmes avec les téléspectateurs.
C'est pas les téléspectateurs qui disent
"J'ai regardé cette émission, c'était
ignoble parce qu'il y avait un tel".
C'est généralement ceux qui commentent
les émissions. Euh donc c'est Twitter,
c'est tout ça.
Donc là vous avez vous êtes dans un cas
intéressant où effectivement ce qui pour
moi caractérise la démocratie,
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
encore discuter sans se mettre sur la
gueule, on peut s'écouter,
on peut pas forcément tomber d'accord
mais au moins faire part de nos
différents.
Ce qui est la caractéristique de la
démocratie et sa force aujourd'hui est
de plus en plus mal vécu par une partie
des gens qui habitent ce pays.
Une toute petite partie heureusement
mais c'est ceux qui crient le plus fort.
Donc forcément ça déteint sur ceux qui
organisent des débats s'il en est qui en
tout cas qui organisent des débats euh
et ça ça a tendance oui à à tuer le
débat.
Est-ce que vous êtes mis des limites
pendant vos débats de l'autocensure,
pendant ces interviews ? Une question
d'internet ?
Oui, on se met toujours des des limites.
Pour moi, la loi est une limite.
Donc les tous les débats de ce soir ou
jamais, la loi, qu'est-ce que nous dit
la loi ? Il y a des opinions qui ne sont
pas des opinions qui sont des délits.
Ces opinions-là n'ont jamais été émises
dans ce soir ou jamais. Euh on en a même
jamais, on ne les a
voilà, c'est ça, c'est une évidence.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre ? Vous avez
des gens
que vous allez pas inviter
parce que leur image est
entachée par un autre truc qui va
parasiter
le si par exemple on est en train de
faire un débat je sais pas moi sur
l'euro
et on vous accuse je sais pas moi
d'avoir
la liberté d'expression
de
on va prendre un débat sur la liberté
d'expression.
Non, ce serait plus compliqué. D'abord,
il y a pas de débat sur la liberté
d'expression. J'en ai jamais fait,
voyez.
Non, non. Si c'estàd que si vous êtes
accusé d'avoir tué votre belle- mère et
que vous êtes par ailleurs un très bon
économiste
sur l'euro, je vais avoir tendance à
vous écarter en me disant bon on va
penser qu'à au fait qu'il a assassiné sa
belle-mère et on n'écoutera pas ses
arguments sur l'euro. Vous voyez, ce
serait ça la limite. Vous avez des gens
aussi que vous allez pas inviter sur
certains débats
[Musique]
c'est-à-dire que vous allez leur image
étant tellement forte et tellement et
tellement problématique déjà vous ne les
inviterez que parce qu'on parle d'eux.
Voilà, j'ai il se trouve qu'on m'a
souvent quelquefois en tout cas reproché
d'avoir invité Dieu donné par exemple.
J'ai toujours invité Dieu donné pour
parler de Dieu donné, défendre Dieu
donné face à des gens qui accusaient
Dieu donné. Et d'ailleurs, personne ne
m'a jamais reproché ces débats au moment
où ils avaient lieu, ni le lendemain. On
me les a reproché après, longtemps
après,
comme avec Tarik Ramadan.
Tarik Ramadan, personne ne m'a jamais
reproché d'avoir fait des débats avec
Tarik Ramadan. Mais
quand quand euh on vous met dans le même
sac avec Plenel,
bah enfin, c'est d'ailleurs personne le
fait à part le premier l'ancien premier
ministre.
Euh qui ça ?
Emmanuel Vals. Mais sinon personne l'a
repris d'ailleurs. C'est marrant euh
de mettre dans le même sac celui qui
organise un débat et celui qu'on accuse
à Tor ou à raison de soutenir les idées
de Tark Ramadan, c'est totalement
débile.
Donc ça mérite même pas d'être commenté.
J'ai même pas répondu.
C'est jeté l'eau probre. Oui, c'était
tenté de jeter le probre et pour des
raisons qui qui ne concernent que que
cet ancien premier ministre. Euh
c'était une façon pour lui de se
remettre en selle, de se ref sur une
vague. C'est c'était quoi ? Sa tête et
j'y tiens pas spécialement d'ailleurs.
Il y a-t-il assez de place ?
Oui, voilà. Et enfin, c'était très très
bête. C'était bête et méchant et euh
voilà, ça mérite même pas de de qu'on
lui réponde.
Mais interrompu, je sais plus ce que
j'étais en train de dire.
C'est classique, vous inquiétez pas. Un
peu perturbé par les travaux d'à côté.
Vous vous êtes sur Europin à l'heure
actuelle.
Comment s'appelle votre émission ?
Repin Social Club.
Pourquoi ce titre ?
Je sais plus.
il m'est venu comme ça.
À l'époque, il y avait pas encore les
débats, c'était seulement la partie
magazine
euh enfin magazine non pas magazine,
interview
culturel, on va dire. Depuis cette
année, je fais une heure de débat de 19h
à 20h, mais ça s'appelle toujours le
Social Club.
Alors, question d'internet, beaucoup de
questions sur News Ring. Qui a-t-il Qui
est-il venu de News Ring ? Pourquoi cela
n'a pas fonctionné ?
Au début, quand on a commencé à créer
News Ring, euh mes associés m'avaient
dit euh
"Ça va faire 3 millions
de vues par mois et cetera." Je leur ai
dit "Les gars, vous à mon avis ça va
faire 1 million.
Ça a fait un million
et il fallait que ça en fasse trois pour
que ce soit rentable." Voilà.
Combien ça coûte une émission comme ça ?
Euh c'était pas une émission Newsring.
News Ring c'était un site de débat sur
internet
en disant ben voilà le débat c'est
toujours limité dans le temps et par le
nombre de participants que soit
quel était le budget de tout ça ?
Je me souviens plus. Je crois qu'on
avait ramassé 2 millions et dei d'euros.
Je crois que c'est ça. Donc l'idée
c'était partout les débats sont limités
dans le temps et en nombre de
participants. Il y a qu'internet qui
peut te permettre d'avoir des débats
illimités et en temps et en nombre de
participants. Mais pour ça, il faut que
les gens argumentent
parce que si tu veux participer au
débat, il faut que tu argumentes.
Sachant qu'on voulait écarter les mecs
qui vont le café du commerce, les
injures et cetera. Donc des arguments,
c'était ça qu'on mettait en avant. Or,
tu t'aperçois, tu as beau fulminer
devant ta télé en te disant "Ah ouais,
si j'étais dans ce soir ou jamais, j'en
aurais des choses à dire." C'est pas
vrai. En réalité, très peu de gens ont
des choses à dire sur les débats et je
m'inclus dedans. C'est pour ça que moi
je suis neutre parce que au fond la
plupart des débats pour argumenter,
avoir de vrais arguments, la plupart des
débats ça m'échappe. Moi, je suis
curieux. J'ai envie de comprendre, j'ai
envie de me faire une opinion
éventuellement. Moi, pas tellement, mais
admettons que les gens aient envie de se
faire une opinion, mais de la argumenter
à défendre une position, c'est très très
différent. Et on s'est aperçu assez vite
que les gens étaient plus nombreux à
lire les ce qui se passait sur news ring
qu'à y participer. Donc déjà ça ça
baisse le nombre de gens. Et puis au
fond, est-ce que les gens ont envie de
débat très long avec beaucoup
d'arguments ? au fond, la plupart du
temps, tu as envie d'être conforté dans
ce que tu penses déjà.
Un jour, un jour, j'ai
je me suis
un peu picoré avec le le directeur du de
la télévision publique russe
et il m'a dit il alors de têtes, il m'a
dit il ne faut pas donner aux gens ce
que tu veux mais ce que les gens
veulent.
Qu'est-ce que les gens veulent ?
Je sais pas. Et moi je suis j'ai jamais
pensé ça. Moi moi je pense qu'il faut
leur donner le meilleur dont tu es
capable,
ce que toi tu rêverais peut-être
d'avoir.
Et puis après on verra bien. Si ça
marche, tant mieux. Ça marche pas, tant
pis. Quand j'ai créé ce soir ou jamais,
je me suis pas demandé est-ce que les
gens veulent l'actualité
euh commenté par les gens de la culture,
les artistes et les intellectuels. Je me
suis pas demandé ça. Les gens, la
plupart du temps, veulent ce qu'ils
connaissent déjà et moi je suis comme
eux. D'ailleurs, en tant que
téléspectateur, en tant que lecteur,
je suis sûrement, comme tout le monde,
j'ai envie de ce que je connais déjà. En
tant qu'animateur, j'ai envie de trucs
que les autres n'ont pas encore fait.
Parfois, ça match.
Voilà, pas toujours.
Question internet. La possession des
chaînes de télé par des millionnaires
est-il dérangeant pour la liberté de la
presse ou la liberté d'émission ?
Moi, je ne pense pas du tout. Pas le
moins du monde.
Ça c'est parce que vous êtes sur
européen ?
Pas seulement, mais il se trouve que je
suis sur Europain, j'y suis très bien.
J'ai jamais eu aucun problème. Jamais
personne n'est venu me dire il faut pas
faire ça parce que
le groupe la gardère et cetera. Jamais.
Maintenant, je suis pas en train de je
présente pas le 20h. Voilà. Alors,
présenter le 20h euh sur la 5 d'an
euh ou de Berlusconi en Italie, je sais
pas ce que ça donnait, mais euh mais je
sais que moi j'ai jamais eu aucun
problème finalement. Je me demande
même si on n'est pas plus libre,
regarde la presse américaine, la grande
presse américaine, elle a toujours été
entre les mains de millionnaire.
Elle a toujours fait un travail
remarquable, en tout cas en terme
d'investigation, bien supérieur au
travail qu'ont puir les Français pendant
des décennies.
Euh je me fie absolument pas à à des
télévisions ou à des radios étatique en
pensant que c'est là qui est la liberté.
Ça peut l'être quand c'est un service
public séparé des intérêts de l'État
comme
c'est le cas maintenant ou pas ?
Comme ça pourrait être le cas
maintenant. Oui, je pense que
ça être le cas. Donc ça pas.
J'en sais rien. J'y suis pas et puis en
plus je suis pas dans les rédactions et
j'ai jamais fait une émission d'enquête.
faudrait demander ça à Éise Lucé à des
gens comme ça. Euh c'est c'est jamais
été mon travail moi.
Donc mais en ce qui concerne mon
travail, je n'ai jamais eu aucun
problème.
Boloré sur Canal Plus,
j'ai jamais été chez Boloré. Je crois
que le problème de Boloré, il est plus
qu'il ne connaît rien à la télé que
autre chose.
C'est le même problème que que sur le
service public. Donc une tendance
pour remonter l'audience à baisser le
niveau, la même chose. Euh est-ce qu'il
est-ce que maintenant moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la stratégie de
Boloré, c'est plus ça. Pour l'instant,
il a toujours eu deux trois coups
d'avance sur ceux qui lui disaient qu'il
faisaient des choses nulles. Et donc
c'est peut-être le cas aujourd'hui. Il a
peut-être deux ou trois coups d'avance,
peut-être qu'il veut aller quelque part.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que Canal Plus,
tel qu'on l'a connu, ça fonctionne plus
économiquement avec des Netflix, avec
des choses comme ça. Donc il faut que
Canal Plus change.
On verra.
Quand quand l'opinion publique voit le
documentaire de Vaskovac, Vascovacci sur
la banque Pach, ne pas être diffusé, que
c'est le service public qui le diffuse,
comment l'opinion publique à votre avis
le perçoit ? Est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
participe à l'affaiblissement de
l'opinion publique dans sa capacité à
prendre confiance dans sa presse ?
Non, pour moi ça participe
essentiellement du fait que l'opinion
publique voit celui qui a pris cette
décision comme le feuxoyeur de sa propre
chaîne. Voilà. Et ce qui est pour moi le
plus important, c'est-à-dire que ce sont
des erreurs de communication
avant tout.
Maintenant, une information comme
celle-ci, de toute façon qu'elle passe
sur telle chade ou sur telle autre, peu
importe, elle passera. Mais celui qui
l'a censuré évidemment ne peut que s'en
mordre les doigts.
Quand on voit
envoyé spécial et toutes les émissions
d'investigation sur France 2, avoir un
des coupes au niveau de leur
journalistes,
pas de commentaire à faire. Je sais pas
je suis pas à cette place- là et j'y ai
jamais été. Euh donc on se dit là aussi,
c'est toujours pareil, on se dit
erreur de communication,
c'estàdire
stratégie.
Oui. Erreur stratégique, c'est-à-dire de
se dire "Bon bah c'est là que je vais
couper.
On devrait anticiper le fait que c'est
là que les journalistes vont dire qu'on
va couper et forcément vous allez avoir
l'air de celui qui censure les émissions
d'information. C'est le b àas. Voilà
votre point. Alors, question d'internet
puis ensuite on va repasser au n autre.
Pourquoi acheter un média ? C'est
rentable. Est-ce que vous comprenez ce
qui est dit dans cette question entre
les lignes ?
Oui, je sais bien. C'est en fait on
achète de l'influence, c'est ça qui est
dit en permanence.
C'est peut-être vrai. Encore une fois,
je n'en sais rien. Il se trouve que moi,
je suis europin et Europin appartient au
groupe la garder depuis une éternité, en
tout cas bien plus longtemps que je n'y
suis. Franchement, si j'avais hérité la
fortune de Jean-Luc Legardeur,
je pense que je serais devenu un
Playboy. Je serai à Saint-Bart, hein,
puisque je crois avoir quelqu'un en face
de moi qui aime beaucoup Saint-Bart.
Euh, je serai à Saint-Bart, je bu je
boirai des cocktails et je m'emmerderai
pas ici avec une radio, avec un groupe
de presse, avec tout ça. Voilà.
Donc je pense que je me souviens d'avoir
eu cette discussion aussi avec Pierre
Berger disait "J'ai aucun pouvoir sur le
monde quand je dis un truc, je me fais
"J' suisu des insultes de la part de la
rédaction et cetera et cetera."
En même temps, je suis obligé de
constater que beaucoup de millionnaires
investissent dans les médias. Je crois
qu'il y a un truc de prestige là-dedans.
Euh mais de là à avoir
un moyen de pression direct sur
l'opinion publique, franchement, j'y
crois pas tellement. Al, je vais avoir
l'air naïf, mais j'y crois pas
tellement.
Question d'internet. Euh, Europain
a-t-il refusé que Ruffin vienne chez
Tadi ?
Oui, je l'ai dit, tout le monde l'a dit
à l'époque et je l'ai dit le premier.
Euh il se trouve mais personne me croit
jamais dans cette histoire mais je vais
vous la raconter quand même. Euh on me
propose d'inviter euh Ruffin pour un
documentaire qui s'appelle Merci patron
et je dis bah oui, il y a pas de
problème. Ouais, c'est un documentaire,
c'est bien. Je ne sais pas de quoi parle
le documentaire. Voilà, il se trouve que
je dis oui sans savoir. Voilà. Et euh et
le matin où il va passer, je crois que
c'est le matin même euh et où je vais
regarder le documentaire puisqu'on m'a
envoyé un lien et que je vais le
regarder comme je fais tous les jours.
Tous les jours, je lis deux livres, je
vois un film, quand c'est un film, la
veille, je suis allé au théâtre, si
c'est le théâtre, c'est toujours au
dernier moment, je fais une émission
quotidienne. Si je commence à à
travailler 10 jours à l'avance, je
meurs. En plus, en travaillant au
dernier moment, si jamais vous oubliez
vos feuilles, vous pouvez faire
l'émission quand même. Ça m'est arrivé
la semaine dernière où il y a 10 jours,
j'avais oublié mes feuilles, j'ai fait
l'émission sans problème. Je venais de
les écrire les feuilles, c'était pas un
problème. Bref, je ne sais même pas de
quoi parle son film. Et il se trouve
qu'on m'appelle le matin, on me dit il y
a un problème. Voilà. Euh le film c'est
sur Bernard Arnaud et euh et à ce
moment-là, on me dit que moi je vais
faire une interview qui est une
interview dans lequelle je me prive pas
de poser des questions emmerdantes à mes
invités, mais c'est pas une interview à
la Jean-Pierre L Cabache pour qui j'ai
beaucoup de respect. Ben d'ailleurs, et
c'est lui qui m'a fait rentrer euh à
Europ, mais c'est-à-dire des interviews
un peu un peu punchy, voilà, où on porte
la contradiction systématique de votre
invité parce que c'est un politique en
général avec une idéologie. Bon, moi
c'est pas ce je peux le faire mais c'est
pas mon truc. Donc je sais que donc a
priori Europin dit bon il faudrait pas
que ce soit une interview promo. Je fais
pas des interviews promo mais enfin
quand même ça c'est une émission qui qui
parle des films des livres qui sortent
donc à priori qui a pas une et donc il y
a pas de problème je leur dis je sais
même pas de quoi parle le film mais en
revanche je vais le dire je vais dire
que c'est pas moi qui tout à coup une
lubie et qui dit
et ils me disent oui ouioui il y a pas
de problème voilà et je le dis et j'ai r
fin au téléphone et quand fin au
téléphone me dit mais vous saviez que je
je dis non mais je crois qu'il m'a pas
cru. Il est persé que je lui ai menti.
Mais c'est une évidence, je peux pas
lire voir les films 8 jours avant mon
émission. Je les vois le jour même.
Est-ce que vous connaissez la charte de
Munique ?
Ouais.
Ça raconte quoi ?
C'est les devoirs et les droits des
journalistes.
Je suis pas très là-dedans, moi. Mais
mais pourquoi c'est important ?
Pour les journalistes peut-être, non ?
Pour l'opinion publique.
Je suis Ouais. Ouais. J'aime bien le
J'aime J'aime bien euh Il y en a un qui
me concerne un peu euh c'est euh le
passage de soupe,
non ? Défendre le droit à l'information,
aux commentaires et à la critique.
Voilà, ça c'est ma partie. Je suis pas
un enquêteur de terrain, je suis pas euh
je suis pas quelqu'un dans une rédaction
qui se demande si il peut livrer cette
information. Je suis pas quelqu'un qui
donne de l'information au sens où les
journalistes en donnent. Moi, je donne
de l'information au sens où les
je donne de l'information sur ce qu'il y
a dans les livres par exemple. Voilà, il
y a des livres qui vous donnent des
informations et à mon avis à mon humble
avis pour bien comprendre le monde
aujourd'hui, vaut mieux lire des livres
que lire les journaux. Voilà.
Alors, question d'internet. Son point de
vue sur les nouveaux médias qui
naissent, tels le média et les chaînes
YouTube, internet peut-il remplacer la
télé et permettre aux gens de faire leur
programme selon leurs goûts et
aspiration ? Bien sûr, évidemment. C'est
ce qui est déjà en train de d'avoir lieu
et ça aura lieu de plus en plus. Euh la
génération de mon fils, il regarde la
télévision mais ils savent pas ce que
c'est de la télévision.
Quel âge ?
18 ans. Tout ce qu'il regarde en vidéo,
on va dire en image qui bouge, c'est sur
internet. Il a il a pas chez moi, il y a
pas la télévision donc je regarde pas la
télévision. Il y a que sa mère qui
regarde la télévision et elle la regarde
dans une pièce spéciale où personne
d'autre.
Voilà. Moi, je ne vois jamais la
télévision. Quand je rentre dans cette
pièce et que la télévision est allumée,
je ressors. Voilà. Mon fils n'a jamais
regardé la télévision, en tout cas avec
ses parents depuis les télbis.
Voilà. C'est la seule fois où il a dû
regarder un programme de télé.
Maintenant, il regarde de la télévision
sur internet et il sait pas que c'est de
la télé. Voilà, il sait pas de sur
quelle chaîne ça passe. Il sait pas il
sait pas d'où ça vient. Voilà, je pense
que c'est une grande partie de cette
génération. Et dans ce cas-là, on va
tous devenir dans ce cas-là. On va
regarder effectivement des programmes
télévisés
qui seront du stock et non plus du flux.
Enfin, ça peut être du flux aussi. Brut
par exemple que je trouve très
intéressant, c'est de la télévision.
Voilà. Mais il se trouve que c'est de la
télévision qui passe directement sur
votre téléphone portable.
Vous avez regardé ce qu'on fait nous ?
Non, je regarde jamais la télé, je
Mais nous, on n pas s on n pas la télé
nous.
Vous êtes de la télé ? Bien sûr, vous
êtes de la télé.
Pourquoi on est de la télé ? Bah parce
que c'est c'est télévisé.
C'est télévisé. Là, on est en train de
faire de la télé. Le fait qu'on la fasse
dans cet endroit-là plutôt que dans un
vrai studio ne change rien à l'affaire.
C'est de la télé, c'est tout. Mais j'ai
rien contre la télé en soi. J'en ai fait
et j'adore ça. Mais il se trouve que en
ce qui me concerne, j'ai d'autres choses
à faire dans la vie et que si je
commence à regarder la télé, j'ai plus
le temps de lire des livres de
C'est quoi le livre de ce matin ?
Aujourd'hui,
malheureusement Johnny Alida est mort.
Donc, j'ai pas eu besoin de lire les
deux livres que j'aurais dû lire
normalement. Et je les ai je sais même
pas lesquels c'est. C'est là où c'est
drôle. Oui,
c'est qui vous les fournit,
hein. Non, mais c'estàd que j'ai dit oui
à un moment ou à un autre, voyez. J'ai
dit oui, ça m'intéresse mais je sais
plus quel c'est et je sais pas forcément
ce qu'il y a dedans. Parfois, j'ai des
surprises désagréables.
Question d'internet. sa vision de la
démocratie actuelle,
ça s'appelle une démocratie
représentative
avec ses défauts et ses inconvénients.
Je vais pas vous refaire la phrase de
Churchill
mais
c'est quoi la phrase de Churchill ? Bah
c'est c'est le plus mauvais des systèmes
à l'exception de tous les autres. Euh
tant qu'on aura pas trouvé mieux.
Maintenant, j'ai suffisamment euh invité
de gens qui avaient des doutes à l'égard
de ce système pour ne pas en connaître
toutes les les faiblesses.
Mais euh mais bon, j'en connais pas
d'autres. Voilà. Maintenant, de toute
façon, je ne vote pas. Donc
pourquoi ? parce que je suis
journaliste.
Et alors les journalistes devraient pas
voter.
Bah non, c'est euh en tout cas tous ceux
qui sont intéressés à organiser des
débats. Moi, j'admet à fait qu'on soit
un journaliste d'opinion hein, c'est pas
la question. Et quand bien et y compris
quand on est un enquêteur, un
journaliste d'investigation, on a le
droit de vouloir combattre machin, ça me
pose aucun problème. Tant qu'après on
déforme pas la vérité sur machin. Mais
en revanche, quand vous organisez des
débats, c'est quand même plus emmerdant
quoi. Alors, évidemment que j'ai des
convictions, des opinions, des préjugés
comme les autres. J'essaie de pas qui ne
déborde pas, qui ne dégueule pas.
J'essaie que les gens que j'invite
viennent dans mon émission en se disant
il va être neutre et ils viennent
d'autant plus facilement qu'il ne savent
pas ce que je crois, ce que je pense.
Donc j'évite de donner mon opinion sur
quoi que ce soit dans tous les domaines.
Et pour aller au bout du compte, autant
ne pas voter comme ça, on n'est pas
parce que dès l'instant où vous votez,
après vous aurez tendance à vouloir voir
triompher les les idées ou en tout cas
les supporters de celui pour qui vous
votez ou pour qui vous allez voter ou
vous voilà. Donc j'ai poussé le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout.
Comment vous percevez l'arrivée de Riaou
sur la télé ?
aucun problème comme Alzira, pas de
problème. Je trouve ça tout à fait
normal que si vous voulez ça fait
partie, c'est un truc qu'on a vécu là
depuis 25 ans, on va dire qui est
passionnant, c'est qu'à un moment on
avait le monopole de tout, nous les
occidentaux si vous voulez, de
l'information,
de l'industrie, des communications,
de la culture, de tout.
Depuis début des années 90, il a fallu
faire de la place aux autres
à tort ou à raison qu'il le fasse bien
ou qu'il le fasse mal. Il a fallu qu'on
leur cède des parts de marché
et ce qui va en plus avec le sens
démographique de l'histoire. Il se
trouve qu'au début du 20e siècle, les
occidentaux représentaient 25 % de la
population mondiale. Aujourd'hui, on est
descendu, je sais pas, en dessous de 15,
je crois. On est peut-être à 12 même,
voyez. Donc, il est absolument normal
que les autres veuillent eux aussi
produire des richesses, produire de la
culture, produire de l'information.
Bon ben voilà, euh
j'ai pas d'a priori contre Russia Toude,
pas plus que je n'ai je n'avais d'a
priori contre CNN ou contre Alzira.
Voilà. Maintenant après vous pouvez
avoir des doutes sur telle ou telle
information de CNN, d'Algesira, de
Russia Toude ou de France 24 ou de
France 2 ou de TF1 et cetera et cetera.
Les fake news, qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ? On fait comment pour les
combattre ? Est-ce que les journalistes
occidentaux ne sont pas responsables de
l'affaiblissement de l'esprit critique
du public ? Et il est-ce que l'esprit
public n'est pas devenu plus perméable
au fake news de Tor ? C'est compliqué.
Je pense que
il y a toujours eu des fake news. Voilà.
Euh, je pense qu'il y en avait
Chernoby genre Ternobyl.
Ah non, pourquoi
les nuages de Ternobyl ? C'était pas une
fake news. Il s
Ah, le fait qu'il passerait pas en
France.
Oh, j'appelle pas ça une fake news.
J'appelle ça de la
un petit arrangement avec la vérité.
Non, j'appelle ça de la
de la démagogie,
de la faiblesse d'esprit. de la bêtise,
de l'ignorance, tout ce que vous voulez,
mais j'appelle pas ça une fake news. La
fake news, c'est l'information fausse
que vous fabriquez
pour tromper le public, que les autres
reprennent par bêtises, par ignorance,
par incompétence,
par incompétence ou par idéologie parce
que ça les arrange.
et que le public avale par ignorance,
par naïveté
ou parce que ça l'arrange et qu'on sait
bien qu'on a envie de croire aux
nouvelles qui nous arrangent. Voilà, ça
a toujours existé. Je pense que quand on
voyait, je sais pas, les 600 quotidiens
qui sortaient en France avant la
Première Guerre mondiale, ça devait être
bourré de fake news. Bourré.
Les guerres ont été propices à toutes
les fake news les plus invissemblables.
La guerre froide a été fascinante, le
combat entre les deux blocs, enfin bon,
tout ça, ça a toujours existé. Il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez là encore, on a du CD des
parts de marché, c'est-à-dire que les
les
politiques, les journalistes, les
professionnels de la parole n'ont plus
le monopole de l'émission de la parole.
Bon et ça on le sait depuis en 1995,
j'invite sur Canal Plus Pierre Lévi qui
à l'époque le grand spécialiste
internet, le mec qui réfléchit internet
génialement bien d'ailleurs, il a été
très peu démenti euh et qui nous dit
voilà c'est fini, on va tous devenir
émetteurs. en 95, on le sait, on sait
aussi que ça va être la fin de la
hiérarchie telle qu'on l'a connu, de que
il y aura plus cette espèce de
centralisation qui va nous dire ce qui
peut sortir ne pas sortir et cetera et
cetera. Tout ce qui fait le journalisme,
trier les informations, les hiérarchiser
et cetera et cetera, c'est fini. Ce sera
bientôt fini et aujourd'hui c'est fini.
À partir du moment où les réseaux
sociaux
sont le moyen pour déjà plus de 50,
peut-être même 60 % des Américains de
s'informer et que les Français doivent
pas être très très loin, vous savez bien
que tout ça est fini et que à partir du
moment où tout le monde est émetteur,
tout le monde peut relayer tout et
n'importe quoi, je pense que les
journalistes étaient eux aussi des
relais de fake news, qu'aujourd'hui ça
s'est démultiplié, ça s'est accéléré
aussi et que donc voilà, c'est une des
raisons pour
parce que vous connaissez l'astrurfing
Oui
oui, j'en ai parlé. Il se trouve que
j'ai fait un débat sur les fake news.
Donc je me souviens que le terme
astrurfing
est revenu et je crois d'ailleurs que
celui qui l'avait créé ce mot était sur
mon plateau. Mais j'ai déjà oublié, il
faut me le rappeler.
Influencer l'opinion publique en lui
montrant avec les usines.
Non. Ouais. Non mais les usines ça peut
être ça ou sinon simplement un
algorithme qui une intelligence
artificielle qui va pondre des
commentaires en faveur de X ou Y. Ça
s'est beaucoup vu en Corée.
Euh euh est-ce que si on est tous
émetteurs mais qu'on est vu par personne
parce que le grand patron de du réseau
social a décidé de mettre un prisme de
lecture sur son réseau relayé par de
l'intelligence artificielle sous
stéroïde. Est-ce que c'est pas le nouvel
ORTF ?
Encore une fois, j'ai pas je ne je suis
un anticomplotiste de Non non non, j'ai
bien compris mais vous allez comprendre.
Je vous l'ai dit, je suis pas
paranoïque. De la même manière, toute
idée de complot possible,
je suis a priori contre. Voyez,
c'est-à-dire que je me dis il ne peut
pas c'est ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça.
Je crois toujours au hasard, je crois à
la liberté, je crois à la possibilité,
quel que soit le système, de pouvoir
passer entre les failles et cetera et
cetera. Donc tout ça fait que euh même
si tout cela existe et je crois
absolument que ça existe, je crois que
ça n'est pas infaillible. Je ne crois
pas à l'hyperpuissance. Il y a jamais
d'hyperpuissance. Donc je crois que tout
est possible, y compris de faire
travailler des robots qui envoient des
commentaires favorables et cetera et
cetera. Évidemment que tout le monde le
fait et tout le monde va le faire. Je
crois évidemment que la NSA peut capter
toutes les communications, mais je crois
que les pauvres sont incapables de les
écouter, de les hiérarchiser et de voir
là où c'est intéressant. vou stocker,
vous les stockz et vous avez une
capacité de calcul pour les traiter à
postériori, on fait quoi ?
Je sais pas, pour l'instant je me dis
euh
elle va bien votre licorne et votre
bisou nours.
Je me dis euh on peut toujours s'en
sortir.
Je sais pas pourquoi une fake news je la
vois moi, j'ai l'impression. Donc voilà
et puis encore une fois, j'ai pas envie
de me dire
vous avez pas peur. Voilà. Non, je n'ai
pas peur. La vie est belle pour ceux qui
n'en ont pas peur. Je n'ai pas peur.
Voilà. Quoi qu'il arrive, je n'ai pas
peur. Le soir des attentats du 13
novembre, je n'avais pas peur. Voilà. Et
le lendemain, j'ai dit à mon fils de
sortir et d'aller boire un verre en
terrasse. Voilà. Jamais avoir peur.
C'est un bon conseil.
Question d'internet. Quels sont les
médias que vous lisez pour vous informer
?
[Musique]
Très peu. Je lis des livres.
Très peu. Dans le très peu au moins
trois.
Courrier international.
Voilà.
J'aimerais le lire plus souvent mais j'y
arrive pas. Mais pour moi c'est aussi
intéressant que les livres sais
économistes.
Voilà.
C'est tout.
À peu près tout. Maintenant, il m'arrive
de lire des articles dans la presse.
Quand je prépare un débat, je vais
regarder ce qu'a dit,
je vais je vais un peu lire Libération
ou le monde ou le Figaro. Voilà. Mais
mais c'est plus pour avoir des chiffres,
des choses comme ça. Moi, je m'informe
euh
je m'informe pas sur l'actualité euh
immédiate. Ça m'intéresse pas beaucoup.
C'est c'est l'écume ça. Moi ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est la mer qui est en
dessous. Voilà. Si vous comprenez ce qui
la mer,
l'écume vous la comprenez.
Si vous comprenez les courants, vous
comprenez l'écume. C'est ça.
Oui, c'est intéressant les courants.
C'est pour ça que j'organise des débats.
Les débats, c'est pas tellement pour
vous faire changer d'avis. Là où les
débats sont intéressants, c'est de
comprendre pourquoi les gens ne sont pas
d'accord.
Si vous avez compris pourquoi les gens
ne sont pas d'accord, donc les courants
contraire et il y en a sur absolument
tous les sujets. Absolument tous les
sujets.
Vous avez fait un grand pas dans la
compréhension du monde et moi ce qui
m'apporte c'est la compréhension du
monde. C'est la comprendre ce qui se
passe autour de moi aujourd'hui. Et ce
qui se passe autour de moi aujourd'hui,
c'est pas ce qui se passait autour de
moi il y a 20 ans.
Est-ce que ça vous épuise
après avoir fait plus de 700 émissions
avec des points de vues dans tous les
sens ? Est-ce que votre disque dur ? Euh
non. Ce qui m'épuisait à la fin de ce
soir ou jamais, parce que tout se
durcissait, c'était la
ce qui m'épuisait, c'était le Oui.
espèce de monté du fanétisme, de
l'antagonisme, de l'hostilité
euh y compris du mensonge, de
l'ignorance qui va avec. Ça ça avait
tendance à m'épuiser. J'avais plus envie
d'être là. J'avais plus envie d'être au
milieu
de tous ces crétins.
Non, c'est pas forcément des crétins.
Euh, il y a parfois des gens très
intelligents qui deviennent haineux
qui veulent la guerre civile. Voilà,
c'est l'impression d'être là où se
répète la guerre civile. Vous voyez,
pour l'instant, on se parle, on est en
train de discuter, on s'envoie des
arguments, mais on sent bien que les
couteaux sont en train de s'aiguiser.
Voilà.
Je l'ai senti à un moment. Je l'ai senti
à la fin de ce soir ou jamais, pas
partout heureusement. Mais j'ai commencé
à le sentir. Voilà. Euh
et peut-être j'avais plus envie d'être
là aussi à cause de ça.
Des émissions sur internet que vous
suivez ?
Rien du tout.
Non non non.
Vous avez un mail ? Vous savez vous
servir d'un ordinateur ? J'espère.
J'ai un mail. Il y a 300 mails non l
dessus.
plus de 30000. Je peux vous le montrer.
Euh
moi je dis toujours aux gens si vous
m'envoyez un mail, vous m'envoyez un SMS
pour me dire que vous m'avez envoyé un
mail parce que sinon j'irai pas de
moi-même sinon je passe ma journée à
lire mes mails. C'est comme je passerai
mes journées à regarder des programmes
télé sur internet. C'est un choix. Après
vous décidez que vous allez regarder des
programmes télé sur internet où vous
lisez des livres, où vous regardez des
films, où vous regardez des séries où
vous vivez. Voyez, le temps est pas
extensible à l'infini, il faut faire des
choix.
Alors, question d'internet. Pense-t-il
que la télévision puisse passer
totalement à côté de sujet et que les
zones à défendre sont un exemple concret
?
Trop compliqué pour moi.
Euh, faut tradu
Faut traduire. Notredame des Landes,
c'estes nouveaux combats, le nucléaire,
on l'a traité. J'ai traité tous ces
sujets. Il y a quasiment il y a
pratiquement aucun débat que j'ai j'ai
pas traité moi et aujourd'hui je les
traite tous sur Europe.
Sur Europédagogue
que de l'était ce soir ou jamais. Ce
soir ou jamais parce que c'est de la
télé, il y a des effets de manche.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
pédagogue ? Il y a à la radio, vous êtes
plus explicite, vous argumentez
davantage, il y a moins de d'effets de
manche lié à l'image qui vont faire
qu'on va essayer de dominer son
adversaire par d'autres moyens que le
contenu, si vous voulez. Euh
je trouve ça très intéressant les débats
que j'anime sur sur Europ. Ça m'a
redonné le goût du débat si vous voulez
que j'avais un peu perdu pour la raison
que je vous expliquais à la fin de ce
soir ou jamais.
Vous êtes seul à préparer les émissions
?
Non.
Combien de personnes ? Comment ça se
passe ? Il y a des fiches ? Pas des
fiches ?
Ah non, j'ai pas de fiches moi.
Faites une réunion avec tout le monde et
tout le monde faire monter ses infos.
Non non non, ça se passe pas du tout
comme ça.
Ça se passe comment alors ? Non non, il
y a pas de briefing, il y a pas de
débriefing, il y a pas tout ça.
Ancienne.
Ouais, c'est au feeling. C'est au
feeling. Vous faites confiance aux gens
avec qui vous travaillez. Ils savent ce
que vous voulez. Vous voulez des gens
qui sont pas d'accord et vous voulez les
meilleurs si possible dans leur partie.
Vous voulez des femmes aussi parce que
moi depuis toujours dans les débats,
j'impose des femmes. Il faut qu'il y ait
au moins un quotat de femme si vous
voulez. C'est pas possible qu'on
C'est la discrimination positive
nécessaire.
Totalement absolument indispensable.
Euh et il faut qu'il y ait des
contestataires, il faut pas seulement
qu'il y ait l'ablishment, le les deux
parties que vous connaissez par cœur qui
sont dans tous les journaux, dans toutes
les émissions, pour et contre. Après, il
faut introduire ceux qui pensent
différemment, les contestataires
et euh
et à partir de là, vous faites confiance
aux gens avec qui vous travaillez, ce
que je faisais ce soir ou jamais et
cetera. Maintenant, tous les gens qu'on
vous propose euh enfin un moment, on
vous les propose. Si vous les voulez
pas, vous pouvez dire "Je les veux pas.
Parfois vous les voulez pas mais c'est
trop tard, on leur a déjà dit qu'ils
allaient venir. Donc comme je veux pas
être mal élevé et que j'essaie de faire
des émissions qui ne se conduisent pas
de manière mal élevée, bon parfois je
les garde alors que je les voulais pas
mais c'est assez rare mais enfin si ça
arrive. Bon donc en gros vous faites
confiance aux gens avec qui vous
travaillez. Euh
les gens avec qui vous travaillez savent
que vous voulez ça savent qu'ils vont
devoir mettre un mouchoir sur leurs
opinions, leurs croyances et cetera. Je
veux pas dire qu'ils essayent pas un peu
quand même d'influerinfluencer
le débat, mais a priori, ils savent
qu'ils sont là, qu'ils vont devoir
inviter des gens qu'ils aiment pas.
Comme moi, je vais être obligé de
recevoir des gens que je n'aime pas. Je
vais être obligé d'entendre des opinions
que je n'aime pas. C'est comme ça.
J'organise des débats, je suis au
service de des gens qui m'écoutent. Et
donc ces gens qui m'écoutent veulent
avoir des visions du monde différentes
qui s'opposent. Et euh et voilà, c'est
ce que je leur donne. Et j'essaie que ce
soit de la meilleure qualité possible,
c'est-à-dire que la pire vision du monde
que je n'aime pas, je vais essayer que
ce soit le meilleur qui la défende. Le
ou la meilleure qui la défende. Voilà.
Et à partir de là,
j'ai besoin de quoi moi ? De savoir
l'enjeu du débat. Mon travail, il est
là. C'est quoi les visions du monde
différentes sur tel débat ? Pour voir si
on en a pas oublié. C'est aussi pour ça
que parfois dans ce soir ou jamais il y
avait trop de monde, 6 personnes parce
qu'il on voyait bien qu'il y avait des
visions très différentes et que c'était
dommage de sacrifier celle-là qui
pouvait amener quelque chose
d'intéressant. Parmi ces visions du
monde, on en revient à ce que je disais
au début, il est pas question là tout à
coup il y a le respect de la loi. On est
bien d'accord, vous allez pas inviter
n'importe quel cinglé sous prétexte que
cette vision du monde est intéressante.
Voyez ?
La haine, celui qui est porteur de tel
type de haine ne pas obligatoirement
invité. Ce pas ce qui représente une
vision du monde. Soit bien d'accord
là-dessus. Mais en revanche, il y a des
visions.
Vous avez pas invité Forisson ?
Non. C'est interdit par la loi Forisson.
C'est simple, il y a pas de
Et vous remarquerez d'ailleurs, on m'a
reproché d'avoir laissé Mathieu
Cassevitz
euh dire ce qu'il pensait le 11
septembre. Je n'ai pas fait de débat sur
le 11 septembre. Euh
c'était un vrai problème pour moi faire
un faire ne pas faire un débat sur le 11
septembre. Euh
finalement qu'est-ce que j'ai choisi ?
Il se trouve qu'au même moment on a
invité un mec qui avait des une vision
complotiste. On l'a invité dans une
autre émission sur une autre chaîne mais
du service public.
C'est
qui ? Je me souviens plus. On l'a invité
et on l'a pas laissé parler. En gros, on
l'a invité et puis on a invité un mec en
face de lui qui pour le pit
qui n'y connaissait rien mais qui a été
de mèche avec l'animateur et on a tourné
l'autre en dérision sans jamais
l'écouter, sans jamais lui laisser la
parole. Pure démonstration de mépris
comme la télévision peut en donner.
Ce qui a renforcé l'empon public,
évidemment, ce qui a renforcé les
complotistes à mort. Donc moi, j'ai fait
le débat sous l'angle et j'ai dit machin
machin été invité et cetera. J'ai fait
le débat, je veux dire faut-il que ce
débat-là sorte d'internet pour venir à
la télévision mais à ce moment-là qu'il
y viennent et qu'il y viennent vraiment
pas de la façon dont il s'y prend là qui
est une façon tellement là encore erreur
stratégique erreur de communication on
est là on caricature et on se rend bien
compte que en fait on fabrique
l'ennemi. On fabrique celui qu'on est
censé dénoncer.
Et donc j'ai posé cette questionlà et
purement cette question là, je trouvais
qu'il y avait qu'à se vide ce soir-là
par hasard, pas prévu, pas invité pour
ça, qui lui croyait à la ne croyait pas
la thèse officielle et qui explique
pourquoi. Et en face de lui, il y a des
tas de gens qui lui répondent qu'il a
tort.
Vous savez pourquoi il croit pas la
version officielle ?
Non. Pour lui, c'est une version déjà
qui a été présentée par des criminels et
pour
rien que pour ça, on doit la regarder à
la loupe.
Oui, mais de toute façon, il a pas temps
en disant que toute version officielle
doit être regardée à la loupe. Et à
partir du moment d'ailleurs où on
revient sur l'affaire Kennedy qui est le
départ du complotisme tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui, on voit bien que
les arguments sont parfaitement sensés à
ne pas accepter n'importe quelle version
de quelque événement aussi important. Et
et c'est très marrant d'ailleurs que on
n' pas du tout la même réaction
vis-à-vis du complotisme en ce qui
concerne l'Assassinat Kennedy qu'on a
rapport avec le complotisme. Et j'ai
posé la question d'ailleurs quand on a
fait là quand on a euh quand les un
certain nombre de documents ont été
mis en public sur Kennedy, j'ai fait le
débat et j'ai posé cette question.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on est tolérant à
l'égard de des de ceux qui qui imaginent
des complots invraisemblables sur la
mort de Kennedy ? Et pourquoi on les
beaucoup moins ? Moi y compris, sur ceux
qui remettent en cause le 11 septembre.
Euh c
qui remettent en cause la version
officielle du 11 septembre. Et c'est
tout ça est très intéressant pour moi et
les gens font complètement la
différence. C'est d'ailleurs, je me
souviens quand j'avais été emmerdé par
quelques journalistes qui m'avaient
reproché d'avoir laissé parler Cassevit
sur ce sujet, je leur ai dit qu'à ma
connaissance, il y avait pas encore de
loi qui interdisait le complotisme et
que si quelqu'un venait me dire que
l'IRV Oswald n'était pas le seul à avoir
tiré sur Kennedy, est-ce qu'il fallait
que j'appelle la police ?
Évidemment, les pauvres journalistes
avaient dit "Ben non, c'est différent."
Mais comme ils ne connaissent rien à
rien. Et c'est aussi le problème sur le
complotisme. C'està-dire que ceux qui se
mêlent de répondre soi-disant au
complotistes ne connaissent rien et que
donc forcément il fabriquent du
complotisme si vous voulez. Et c'est ce
que je leur avais dit aussi. Je leur ai
dit moi je sais pourquoi je suis contre
les complotistes. Vous je suis pas sûr.
Et si demain c'est les complotistes qui
prennent le pouvoir, vous m'engueulerez
comme vous m'engueulez aujourd'hui. Vous
m'engueulerez de défendre des positions
non complotistes. Donc on est dans on
est dans le l'ignorance encore une fois
et l'incompétence généralisée. Mais tout
ça pour dire que je n'ai pas fait ce
débat par exemple dans ce soir ou
jamais. Je n'ai pas fait le débat sur le
sur le 11 septembre pour une raison,
c'est qu'il me semble qu'il était devenu
impossible de le faire. Ça aurait pris
trop de temps. Ça aurait ça aurait été
invraisemblable. C'est-à-dire que tout
le monde et d'ailleurs ça a été fait
après ce que
ce qu'avait dit Cassevit chez moi, il a
été invité chez Guillaume Duran à
l'époque. Ils ont fait une espèce de
similie débat avec Cassovit et je sais
plus qui à côté de lui, Jean-Marie
Bigard, je crois qui était représent
censé représenter les complotistes et
puis je sais plus qui en face. Ça devait
pas être beaucoup plus brillant et
c'était une espèce de débat de
d'unigjambiste
combat
il a beau s'intéresser à l'histoire, il
travaille pas là-dessus quoi. Vous voyez
c'est n'importe quoi.
Question d'internet. Comme on fait face
aux gars femmes, au pub, à la télé qui
prend qui alors il faut écrire les gars
correctement
c'est les gafta, ils veulent dire non
non non non, on va reformuler la
question.
Comment on se remet à lire et à
s'informer aujourd'hui ? Problème
d'éducation. Comment on fait face au
gars femme, au pub, à la télé qui
prennent toute notre attention ?
Bah faites comme
Comment on fait pour éviter de se faire
aspirer le cerveau ? On coupe tout, on
met une pièce avec une grosse porte pour
la télé.
Je sais pas.
Il y a des marques dans lequel dans
lesquelles on peut être
avoir plus de confiance qu'en les
autres, chacun ayant les siennes. Euh
moi, je crois qu'on s'informe plus dans
les livres que dans les journaux, mais
c'est pas vrai surtout, on le sait bien
parce que les livres, il y a un peu de
décalage. Donc il faut avoir confiance
dans un certain nombre de journalistes,
de titres de presse, d'organes
télévisuels ou ailleurs. Il faut il faut
faire confiance à ceux à qui on a
confiance et le jour où ils trahissent
notre confiance, il faut il faut rompre,
c'est tout.
Rompre.
Oui, rompre. C'est-à-dire qu'il faut
plus faire confiance à celui qui vous a
trahi. C'est comme dans la vie, quoi.
Comme en amour.
Ouais. Après, est-ce que c'est si
important que ça d'être informé sur tout
? C'est ça la grande question. Moi, j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut comprendre le
monde dans lequel on vit. Faut pas vivre
dans ce monde avec les repères qu'on
avait du monde précédent d'il y a 20 ans
ou il y a 30 ans. Parce que là, on vous
dit ce qu'on entend toute la journée, ce
monde est devenu incompréhensible, il
est trop complexe, on sait plus où on
va, trop de violence, tout ça c'est des
conneries. Le monde il est très
compréhensible aujourd'hui comme hier.
Il y a pas plus de violence qu'avant, il
y en a plutôt beaucoup moins. Mais tout
ça, on peut le savoir. Les guerres
aujourd'hui font moins de morts
qu'autrefois, moins de morts que quand
j'étais petit. Je parle même pas de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale. Moi, j'étais
enfant dans les années 60. Il y avait
beaucoup plus de morts dans les guerres
dans les années 60 70 qu'aujourd'hui.
Euh et cetera et cetera. Tout doit être
remis en perspective.
Dans les années 70,
il y avait peut-être plus de morts mais
il y avait peut-être moins de zombies.
Non, il y a plein de zombies dans les
années 70. Vous rigolez ? plein de
zombies, il y avait des terroristes.
Euh les terroristes à mon avis chez nous
en tout cas faisait moins de morts
qu'ils n'en ont fait récemment.
Euh maintenant on a tendance à revenir
aux attentats anarchistes. Là les
attentats anarchistes faisaient plus de
morts que aujourd'hui. Les anarchistes
étaient quand même autre chose. He les
anarchistes, il vous butaient des rois,
des présidents de la République. Il y a
pas un djihadiste aujourd'hui qui est
capable d'aller buter un roi ou un
président de la République. Impossible.
Euh les mecs, il vous mettaient des
grenades des bombes dans l'Assemblée
nationale, il vous balançaiit des
grenades dans les cafés. c'était
autre chose, hein. Euh aujourd'hui,
c'est particulièrement sanglant et
dégueulasse. Les attentats du 13
novembre, tirer sur des femmes, des
enfants, des jeunes et cetera. Ça nous
paraît absolument répugnant et horrible.
Je sais pas si c'était comme ça du temps
des anarchistes. Voilà. Mais c'était pas
comme ça du dans les années 60-70 où le
terrorisme était ciblé. C'était la
police, c'était les ministres, c'était
euh c'était les deux tournements d'avion
aussi, on l'a oublié. Mais les
tournements d'avion, ça ressemblait
beaucoup à
enfin d'une autre manière. Voilà. Bon,
enfin bon, de toute façon, ça sert à
rien. Je m'embarque dans un truc. Ce
genre de comparaison n'a pas
d'importance.
Dans 15 ans, vous voyez où ? Écrire des
bouquins à Saint-Bart. Non, mais j'écris
pas de livre moi.
Ouais. Dans 15 ans.
Dans 15 ans, ouais. Peut-être que
j'aurais envie d'écrire un livre sur la
télévision. Je trouve qu'il y a pas de
bon livre sur la télévision. Ça serait
peut-être intéressant enfin un grand
livre, un truc un peu littéraire, un peu
Ouais. Mais bon, j'ai j'ai je voulais
être écrivain et j'ai j'y a renoncé
parce que par manque de talent. Donc il
faut être Non, c'est si vous voulez être
écrivain, c'est pas pour être dans la
rentrée de de septembre ou janvier là.
Évidemment, tout le monde peut y être
mais non, c'est de c'est de rivaliser
avec Dostoyevski, avec
Skoffy Gérald, avec Patrick Modiano,
Tolstoy,
voilà avec Tolstoy. Et là, je j'étais
pas j'étais pas compétent. Maintenant,
je peux remplacer le manque de talent
par l'expérience.
J'ai vécu des trucs.
Tu par beaucoup de travail. Non.
Ah non, c'est autre chose le travail
c'est autre chose. Non non, c'est
l'expérience, le ressenti. J'ai été dans
le poste, vous voyez, je suis encore
d'ailleurs. J'ai été dans le poste et ce
que ça fait d'être dans le poste, c'est
intéressant.
En quoi ça vous change ? En quoi
en quoi ça vous change pas ? D'ailleurs,
c'est quand même un endroit particulier.
C'est une aventure moderne. C'est comme
cosmonaute. Voyez, c'est une aventure
moderne cosmonaute.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des hackers ?
Je les aimais beaucoup dans les années
90.
Je les trouvais très drôle.
Très drôle. Et
toujours très drôle. Oui, oui, mais très
drôle et
pas méchant.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent être
méchants. Ils sont devenus méchants. Euh
ce qui a fait beaucoup de Thorers, c'est
la façon dont Hollywood les a les a
incarné généralement par un Chinois.
Euh, si souvent dans les films
américains, mais c'est surtout toujours
un type capable de faire des trucs qui
sont totalement invraisemblables
techniquement. On a
Vous avez vu monsieur Robot ?
Non. On vous le conseille.
Ouais. Mais non, ce qui est drôle c'est
que quand vous êtes vous avez un
scénario un peu compliqué, vous savez
pas comment vous en tirer. Vous appelez
le hackur chinois et généralement il
trouve un truc pour vous
jamais vu le film où il y a un hackur
qui doit forcer
qui doit forcer un mot de passe et
pendant qu'il il force mot de passe, il
y a une jeune demoiselle qui lui pompe
le dart. Vous avez pas vu ça ?
Non, je me souviens pas de ça.
Voir ça.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des lanceurs
d'alerte ? Alors traitement médiatique,
c'était opération Espadon. Bien vu les
gars, merci.
Euh le film Opération Espadon, bien sûr
que je l'ai vu. Oui. Non mais il est
totalement invraisemblable Opération
Espadon. Mais c'est un bon film. C'est
un bon film d'aventure. Et euh des
lanceurs d'alerte,
j'ai rien contre.
Snowdon à Sange. On va rester sur
Snowdon, on verra à Sange après.
Beaucoup de respect.
beaucoup de respect, ne serait-ce que
parce que
ils ont beaucoup plus perdu à à lancer
leurs alertes qu'ils n'y ont gagné.
Essayer de se faire protéger par la
France et par sa loi qui ne les protège
pas.
Bien sûr, mais c'était logique qu'on les
donne pas l'asile.
Mais oui, bien sûr que c'était logique.
C'est notre allié les États-Unis, on
peut pas. Alors oui, bien sûr. Est-ce
que c'était logique que les Français ne
Non mais je vous dis pas que c'était
bien, je vous dis que c'était logique
pas s'attendre à sachant que les
Français à la limite peut-être du temps
de du général de Gaulle, on leur donné
l'asil, vous voyez parce qu'à l'époque
on se voulait indépendant mais ça fait
longtemps que les présidents de la
République en France enfin depuis au
moins trois deux présidents précédents,
je sais pas encore ce qui va
sont plus indépendants. ben que en tout
cas qu'on a voulu au contraire rassurer
les Américains par notre amitié
indéfectible. Forcément, ça vous oblige
à ne jamais rien faire qui puissent les
contrarier ou en tout cas à être
toujours ou à peu près toujours du même
avis que euh
Chir qui a été le dernier à à se dresser
à un moment, on s'en souvient tous. Vous
vous rappelez de l'affaire Farwell ?
Oui, bien sûr. Mitteran. Mitteron,
c'était une façon de rassurer son allié
l'affaire Farwell. À un moment où
l'allié se dit "Attendez, ce type arrive
avec des ministres communistes, donc
est-ce que la France est en train de
changer de camp ?" Et Mitteran grâce à
l'affaire Farawell montre qu'on a pas du
tout l'intention de changer le camp et
que et que et que voilà. Donc euh
maintenant, quand on veut rassurer son
allié pour lui montrer qu'on n'est pas
son ennemi, euh parfois on a tendance à
à pas le contrarier sur des trucs
notamment sur des trucs symboliques.
Mais euh on sait bien que Snowden à
Sange
en étant des ennemis de l'État sont pas
seulement des ennemis de l'État
américain, ils sont des ennemis de
l'État quel qu'ils soit, y compris de
l'État français. On peut pas s'attendre
à ce que les Français tout à coup
trouvent que oui, ce serait de
l'opportunisme.
Donc comme Poutine accueillant Snowden,
voyez, c'est de l'opportunisme. Les
amis, les ennemis de mes ennemis sont
mes amis.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que vous avez euh un conseil à
laisser aux jeunes générations ? C'est
une question qu'on laisse toujours à
tous nos invités.
J'ai dû dire plein de conneries. Donc le
donc ne les prenez pas au pied de la
lettre.
Ne me jugez pas mal sous prétexte que
j'ai peut-être dit des conneries ou des
choses auxquelles vous avec lesquelles
vous n'étiez pas d'accord. Ne me
détestez pas par principe. On n'est pas
obligé de détester les gens avec qui on
n'est pas d'accord. On n'est pas obligé
de les haïr. Euh
servez-vous de votre intelligence,
de la vôtre. Ne misez pas tout sur
l'intelligence des autres. Ne faites pas
une confiance aveugle à des gens euh
assis sur des canapés devant des caméras
comme ça et et qui vous refont le monde
et qui ont l'air de
de savoir de quoi ils parlent. Ils
savent pas forcément.
Euh et leurs intentions ne sont pas
toujours très bonnes, ne sont pas
toujours aussi purs qu'il voudrai nous
le faire croire.
Euh,
soyez pas ma qu'artiste,
c'est l'ambiance en ce moment.
L'interdiction professionnel, le soupçon
permanent,
l'amalgame.
Euh,
il y a un gros gros truc macariste en ce
moment en France.
sur un peu tous les sujets d'ailleurs
hein, j'ai pas de
Ne croyez pas toujours au complot,
croyez au hasard et aux coïncidences,
elles ont beaucoup plus fait dans
l'histoire du monde que les complots.
Euh,
informez-vous un minimum, mais quand
même un peu pour pas qu'on puisse vous
faire avaler n'importe quoi. Maintenant,
la question c'est où s'informer ? Je
pense que ça va être de plus en plus
difficile. On n pas trouvé de modèle
économique. Les journalistes se sont
paupérisés, les rédactions aussi.
Je sais pas comment ils vont faire.
Liser des livres.
Frédéric Tadi, merci,
c'est un plaisir.
Cut.
[Musique]